So I hope that by now many of you have had a
chance to see my interview with Lex Freedman on
his podcast. It's about three and a half hours
long. If you haven't, we've link to it on the
press page at David Pakman dot com. You can find
it on Lex's YouTube channel. It's on his audio
podcast. Check it out if it's interesting to you.
One of the things that came up and generated a lot
of discussion is the discussion about Wokeness
and to some degree as a relation in relation to
that cancel culture. And I want to delve into
cancel culture here a little bit more because
I think that it has become untenable to continue
even for a second, pretending pretending that the
cancel culture is prevalent anywhere other than
the American right wing. Now, I know that some of
you will say, but David, hold on a second. It's
the right wing that has been messaging for years
now. We are against cancel culture, war, against
cancellation. We're against all of that stuff. It
is the left that cancel, cancel, cancels. Like
with most of these things. It is the height of
projection from the American right wing. It is
they accusing the left of that which they are
guilty of themselves. They say we're against
business regulation. We're against it all
except when they want to force Twitter
to publish their cover. Nonsense. All
of a sudden now Twitter should be forced. To
publish COVID disinformation or businesses.
If you want to require a mask, you shouldn't
be allowed to do it. New law. You can't require
masks if that's what businesses want to do.
Rather than letting the free market decide.
I'm aware of bookstores that to this day require
masks, and I'm aware of people that choose not
to go to those bookstores because some people
are over the masks. That's everybody's choice.
Nobody's interfering. I thought that was the
way that the right wanted regulation done. Okay,
that gets us to cancel culture. Think of the
framing from the right wingers, which is we
will not let the left keep canceling the left
or the cancels, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
The book banning movement, the height of
cancellation, growing and growing and growing.
And it is the right that is banning books, which
is a form of cancellation. They are creating law
to restrict the phrases, terms and topics that
teachers should be allowed to use or better said
should not be allowed to use. That's an insane
form of cancellation. They want to cancel Disney
because Disney supported the don't say gay bill.
They want to cancel Eminem's because one of them
was androgynous or whatever. That was crazy.
They want to cancel Bud Light because Bud Light
did a promo with a trans woman and all of it over
choices that businesses are simply making. They're
not against the law. They don't create any legal
issue. Colin Kaepernick knelt during the national
anthem and then was involved with Nike. They
wanted to cancel Nike because Colin Kaepernick
was in a Nike ad and in fact, they wanted to
cancel the NFL at one point because people weren't
standing during the national anthem. They wanted
to pull public funding for stadiums, the NBA. They
wanted to cancel because the NBA has gone, too,
woke with Dr. Fauci. It's cancel arrest in prison.
Some even said execute Fauci, Execute Fauci.
Some went as far as to say because Fauci was
too arrogant or something about medical knowledge.
Meanwhile, they were listening to Trump's medical
advice. Liz Cheney Cancel. She's the wrong type
of Republican. There's no room for her. Cancel
her Republican credentials. She can't be in the
Republican Party. Kick her out. Other Republicans
who simply don't believe Trump won in 2020, Mitt
Romney cancel him as well. They want to silence
people who are woke on Twitter. They want to
cancel drag shows that aren't being forced upon
anybody. It's up to parents. Do you bring your
kids to a drag show or don't you? By the way,
the other day, this is the season now for Pride
Parades. And I ended up wandering through a
couple of pride parades over the last few weeks,
and I laughed to myself as drag performers
came by or, you know, all sorts of different
things. I laugh. Imagine seeing this. You know,
I had my baby daughter with me. Imagine seeing
this and thinking, Oh, my goodness, shield her
from this. This could this could damage her. This
could ruin her in some way. It's bonkers stuff,
but they want to cancel all of it. Black Lives
Matter definitely deserves to be canceled as well.
How did these folks become such snowflakes? Afraid
of everything and wanting to invoke in so many of
these cases the power of the state, The power of
the state? Not in all, but in many of these cases,
the power of the state to control and to cancel
as well. So we have to really understand that.
If you zoom out, I've been telling you for
a while now, they've essentially abandoned
policy because they're losing on policy. They're
running on anti-abortion. The country mostly wants
abortion to be legal. They're wishy washy on gay
marriage and sometimes completely against it.
The country wants gay marriage to be legal by
a large majority. They're running on don't tax
rich people. The country, by and large, thinks
taxing the very rich to fund social programs is
a good idea. They're running on to do nothing
about guns when more than 80% of the country
says at least pass a background check law, that
doesn't let any transaction circumvent requiring
a background check, even transactions between
people who know each other. They're running
against that. They're off on all of the
policy. So they go, well, the left wants
to cancel. But really, it is they who want to
cancel. Don't fall for it. Don't fall for it.